here we go three minute madness yeah
just some quick action here and I'm
going to go with the with the Dutch just
fire fire fire and as we already know
yeah this is a friend of mine and he
knows his stuff here in the Leningrad
mm-hmm yep and I don't this is a problem
if you play that opening and you really
don't know stuff you've got you got
problems I'm just playing as quickly as
possible 96 as possible maybe okay you
didn't do that to take this Bishop um
chair this bloody pawn down on e 7 look
at seven is losing stuffing so let's go
here I can push the Queen back but I
don't know if that really helps hey I
cannot take that pawn down okay I don't
want to trade a little bit should should
be a should have should be helpful in
general tech is your heart my night on a
six is just a look yeah yuck apiece can
I get that into the game somehow I don't
know he allows night c5 hmm
it's so probably good from white but
yeah it's attacking c6 yeah that's the
problem he wants to take on c6 and if i
take on f6 that looks like complete
rubbish so i have to go here right
that's not good that's not good at all
hmm is that such I don't know that looks
actually it doesn't look like the most
problematic continuation I mean I'm
still probably in some trouble but I
thought there are even even more serious
problems so maybe I can invade on b3
let's invade on b3 if possible so let's
h5 and stuff but I don't know how bad
that is let's go here I'm behind on the
clock yeah that's really crazy it's
crazy because it's really not not that
quick a player but i'm i'm always able
to place to play a even slower okay i
know ma'am i have to take all right so
it stood still fairly fairly stable this
pollution I don't see him how he wins
this quickly taking here d 7 is a way to
win it proclaim still have got 93 time
morning maybe just here it goes into a
pin but it's still not bad check hmm why
am I don't on time that I would be very
interested to know
I it's pinned ya it's pinned you idiot
it just pinned I can do this though some
end games might be even good for me
because my king is near his pawns can
take you actually maybe over here now I
think you he has screwed that up 44 yes
that's a good news let's take everything
here can cover you seven it's very very
necessary not giving that one up so I
have to really be get home check just
push the porn Sam
yeah just go ahead yeah check push
everything check unfortunately check
good for a second so in miniature check
check somehow it's not working with my
pranks checkmate yep one second but one
second is enough yeah that was a bad
position but who cares it three minute
madness so it's just fire away I was
really really slow they're out of the
opening okay next game gives me white
white for money started yeah Mr
sauerkraut I came now should have played
some some sort of sideline i guess but
ok that also will be will be somewhere
crazy because I don't know the open
Sicilian not really ok that's is his out
for sacrifices himself he's got d5
coming that looks dangerous I better
kids not not that much of a problem at
always have night be three to cover
stuffing so let's get this in I know if
I go G for f1 I g3 is coming ok maybe I
can trade trade that night and get out
of this possible attack
this one or is this too loose he might
just go back right yep okay cannot go fo
I just drop stuff I e5 is a good move
now if I've m and E five kills is bishop
I'm sorry I thought if I 494 but his
bishop is more important objectively
speaking I think I'm okay here but it's
um it's not easy how does he doing hina
for check now we go now we can go ahead
here or for bishops III I've been quick
so I'm okay with the time these six is
falling that's really not falling but
very close very close to that let's just
double down g5 i have e 5fo is not
really hanging the doubling is good i
have good control here in this position
i am not sure about this idea c5 g5
let's just cover that cover you fall
don't want to give him the square there
for the night there five square I don't
know how to go ahead here difficult
difficult to play and without giving him
that maybe man I don't be three has to
be re-routed yeah his his sir simply
simply going ahead after the capture
he's in this pin on the D file thought
is a good decision and I was really
played quickly I really did so rookie
five nights nights e5 maybe and then
take take 125 couple of times and I can
take and take here that's good i'm off
tonight if I am mighty force is a pretty
pretty substantial move wow black resign
totally killed him in that game I don't
know why exactly but it was kind of I
really played quickly him sometimes just
everything started ok the next guy year
playing DeMarcus or for the Latvian wow
I've removed f5 almost equal fy5 that
that's a difference to the Kings gambit
body oh but that's not a good idea I
shouldn't have allowed that move ok but
ok maybe Knight f6 is actually useful
tempo I mean Steinitz for example he
played some wacky stuff this is this is
the same same kind of leak ok d for he's
taking on evo
I cannot do that h6 also not good mm
yeah that is probably just rubbish not
not a big surprise huh still is there
some way to play this I wonder okay
let's still do that it's it's okay it's
not moving that okay I thought check
okay anyway why this better but white is
better also here of course I still
didn't expect that thought you would
just take on eharm ok tiik here yeah
mm-hmm the rook to d1 that's a you that
an issue really big one this runs into
Bishop c4 check oh what a mess yeah fy5
that's not really it's really not
something to to recommend 923 coming I
don't know it's just bad
t 97 what a piece and can even go I
could have played before even but ok
it's not really not really important it
is it is losing in quite a number of
ways um yeah it's got f5 coming
f5 Bishop c5 or something I just totally
lost me is Scott rook f7 as well ok I
just tried to irritate him me a little
bit but objectively speaking I'm Jack
I'm just toaster chairman check huh that
was the best i don't know i mean
probably it doesn't matter but it does
maybe not matter much what is he doing
now I can take age three right or is
there a great thing now yeah Queenie six
but I have this move and I takes us just
winning up it is just winning hmm time
warning ok
Queenie yeah I 87 is collapsing now that
wasn't playable it was simply not
playable fy5 that was that was to d4
then what okay but if you play that
quickly you have to read if you have to
accept some losses okay so let's fire
here and the Sicilian with Queen deform
what are you doing ok so maybe here I
don't know sometimes you have to go with
c4 but that's not really a according to
my aggressive intentions I really like
Chile I like to get this position with
long castles and something like that is
even roughly theory at least I think
this move I really don't know maybe it
is right um I think you do something
like that 94 and then a 3g form
that's not good if you get this in hmm
that's not i can I don't have a five I
forgot your age to you one actually this
is part of the would set up yeah that's
unfortunately a really bad position
really bad yeah Black is opening up the
position for his bishop pal and it's
just quite substantially better
coordinated I didn't think that this is
the problem really but okay
I don't know I thought it other things
were a bit more critical but ok so over
here I didn't take it he didn't take it
in the first place mmm so what is he
going for the eight point probably but i
can still annoy him a little bit with
this now maybe over here the long
diagonal should be a good place for that
Queen g3 as a potential move ok that was
a quick decision what is this year I
really I really thought I have this idea
ok sorry threatening made with the
bishop f6 I thought that this is a
pretty substantial issue but he didn't
react to it Bishop g7 h6 maybe it's not
may eat em because it can go to have
eight but still not much fun
hmm Jeff no is taking a huge timeout him
okay so um even h6 comes into
consideration but cat taking it cannot
be bad so we'll check here and just play
this position okay um why there because
your text d 1 mm that's a very good
reason um I don't have a track them no
check on d6 or something time morning
okay let's just protect it it doesn't
feel ideal but cannot spend super long
time on that so try to get to h6 Queenie
for should be quite okay so maybe let's
get out of the checks
ya can ride annoying quite an annoying
move so here he has to check with the
Queen anyway here to do that mmm how to
play maybe here getting that in and if
you take just a check up on check for
Luke c7 but it's just one check doesn't
help that much this chance is good
though took me around check check check
know you're trying to do some speed
demon thing I'm not that chat slow check
check black forfeits on time hey caught
up a little bit on the clock but not
enough okie dokie next one ya head to
him get get to some tricks there Bishop
g7 but he could have just if you would
have just if you just had prevented that
so I'm trying to say that wasn't any
good but Bishop g7 was a neat little
trick at least ok
I tried to get a new game here huh it
really takes uncannily long there's a
couple of games going on but I know tix
takes a bit at the moment that's more
five game started action at the moment
okay Donald Draper nope no name okay so
let's go for the Smith Mora is playing a
deadline this quick development line
yeah what is it that mr. esselman is
recommending against it something
something well probably i know i don't
remember though it's not that as studied
it in much detail that that book but
yeah i was looking at it on and off so i
think was it something with fy5 it seems
a bit slow to be honest but maybe it
still is right okay just feels like a
regular Sicilian way okay I'm lacking a
part the sea 2.44 pretty much nothing
but maybe this is the wrong way the
wrong way to see it I came hmm yeah FIV
five I'm really just a pawn down for
nothing
and he can take the second phone he just
i mean i know he's probably just a bit
cautious here saying that ok i already
have one point in the back why do I need
to grab a second one but objectively
speaking can just take that pawn on your
form I know actually have Queen g4 at
the end now ok ok I understand that's
that's in fact that's not that that
clear or not it's not that good actually
in fact yeah I'm okay it's maybe not not
that terrible then ok but now I think I
have to do something here just playing
for some strategic compensation some not
enough but some if I get the Queen on d5
at the end oops now it takes her I
didn't expect that move I thought this
would be good
I thought that this would be good I make
a maybe you can sacrifice the exchange
somehow okay so i have f 6 as a
potential move or take that first and
take that house then f six so we should
give no we didn't go Bishop g5 Wow ok
I'm going for Pepsi two Pepsi two end
made on age seven that's the plan now
that that's now very very dangerous if
not downright good from what it is good
for what what is this move actually here
I don't see your mouth and then it's
just it's just not let's just not
playable I Bishop c5 maybe you can clear
the f eight square somehow and say I
don't don't really believe believe it's
possible ok what if I let's see that I
cannot win immediately I think so let's
do that and now in the check check so
Queen takes our group chicks maybe look
check this easier
Queen takes Queen g6 a thought so how to
do this now g5 or what is the that looks
it looks very strong besides the fact
that you probably will lose on time and
queen somewhere h5 h3 what is good h3
maybe OS there better one Queen have
five Queen a 50 Queen age 60 page five
time morning why is this that's I I
actually thought um rook age seven but
that it's not I that is working actually
check it is working check so this check
black forfeits on time yeah and and also
the position is toast yeah just he just
lose gather the whole the whole set of
pieces actually yeah that got downhill
really quickly I don't know yeah i just
i'm just a pawn down i think it looks it
looks v area it just looks like a normal
position but that's important missing
okay well let's have another game they
have gained starting killer instinct yep
i'm going ahead with no can we get
something other something crazy like
here the chi Goren not an opening i
usually play okay my idea would be to to
go for quick quick long castles and
attacking him it's not that it's not
super solid but maybe I can still do
that
ok and a weighty can take with the pawn
I shouldn't primigi for you taking where
the point is actually quite good and ok
it's dangerous business I mean this is
not a bad player here and playing in
that insane style might be might be
costly but ok no risk no fun I no guts
no glory as someone recently wrote in
the commentary in a commentary in a
comment on the video so yeah I have to
have to irritate him oops four-night f5
stick here and then night if I he's got
to check there oh wow he didn't give the
check I don't know why but it would have
been awkward yeah this is definitely a
little bit this this medicine is too
strong in the game here I'm not really
in good shape but ok i get i get to
Castle that's that's actually more than
I expected ok maybe I can somehow summer
play this nonsense still some ideas d
4chan it's kind of the only movie
otherwise you really don't know what my
my whole position is doing I have to
open it up hmm it's not I mean it's not
good but it's not like completely self
evident how wet wide wins oh wow he just
runs into this what is the check ok it's
still not bad so
95 95 maybe or can I am a skeptic winter
is six so now that's probably the right
idea the right start at least can i play
some night a five business and irritate
him with that go into a form hmm I
wonder let's start with that Queen a4ai
one there there's some kind of really
hmm I might have sacrifices ships III
Teague's Queen check okay
normal normal measures won't cut it here
anyway yes that I of course I overlooked
that move would have been yes sign
morning yeah yeah yeah it's good so okay
I check there I don't know how to play
it or if I had to have no time
whatsoever no time it's simply not
working and say that's a real problem it
is not working but ok Knight takes
Knight takes Queen e4 check so maybe
this is an this is this is some kind of
I can be irritating at least it's the
last to just take with the night he
didn't why didn't you do that ok maybe I
can what don't don't get that can I hey
I can just retreat now right they have
nights you for coming wow this is this
is getting serious I have some some
serious ideas now check
checkmate mate is good made us good yeah
that was of course totally totally lost
but ok it was crazy enough i guess for
the three minute madness yeah okay i
hope you enjoyed this fun right thanks
for watching